[Music]
you know what they say it's all fun and
games until someone gets hurt from sky
dancers to CSI fingerprint kits that
contained asbestos these are the toys
that should have never been made in the
first place wait until you see how
dangerous the fidgets spinner gets make
sure you give this video a big thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel now sit back relax and check out
these 10 toys that weren't supposed to
be for kids growing up skipper if
there's a toy out there that really
wasn't meant to be for children its
growing up skipper skipper was launched
in 1964 and she was supposed to be
Barbie's younger sister skipper had
blond hair a red headband and a cute red
blue and white dress seems pretty
standard right well this Mattel toy came
with a huge controversy when people
learned how skipper grows up the toy was
meant to teach kids about puberty but
was this the right way to show it
to make skipper grow you had to turn her
arm and watch as she would grow half an
inch taller with that she would also
develop her feminine features including
breasts the toy was advertised as two
dolls in one but for a lot of parents
this was simply one of those products
that should never have made it out into
public
many were outraged and grimace teza
thought of having a boy version of the
doll while others said it was completely
normal what's your take on teaching
children about puberty through Barbie
dolls growing up skipper definitely
isn't the only controversial toy out
there many seem to think our next edible
toy should never exist but children
can't seem to stop playing around with
it candy cigarettes but we always talk
about Mattel in other videos so let's
explore some other questionable toys out
there another kids product that
shouldn't really be on the market for
children are candy cigarettes as a child
did you ever pretend that you were
smoking by breathing out cold air we can
imagine almost everyone did that we
thought we were cool and that it made us
look like grown-ups well this toy takes
it a little bit further candy cigarettes
are just what you think they are they're
edible but they come in a packaging
that's very similar to the actual
cigarettes while this is an edible
product kids also use them as toys as
they often show off and pretend they're
smoking but these edible toys raise an
important question should we
children think smoking is cool and fun
in the first place a 2007 survey asked
26,000 adults that smoke if there was a
correlation between their habit and
candy cigarettes consumed in their early
lives 22% of current smokers and former
smokers also consumed candy cigarettes
in their childhood could it be just a
coincidence or is there really a link
between the two the doctor who conducted
the research also mentioned that tobacco
companies market their products before
kids are even mature enough to hold an
actual cigarette while candy cigarettes
might be a funny kids product is it
really a product that kids should play
with in the first place it's definitely
an ongoing debate but we think candy
should come in more original shapes than
just something that resembles a
cigarette shave the baby doll it's safe
to say this toy is a little bit
disturbing and out of all the toys on
our list it's probably the craziest yes
shave the baby is a toys name and it's
exactly what you think it is luckily
this is just an art piece but we hope a
toy maker won't get inspired and turn
the babies into a real product
disturbing is not even a strong enough
word that describes this art project and
we're really not sure what the meaning
is behind it if you think you have an
idea please let us know in the comments
this project comes from Warsaw in Poland
and it was created in 1995 it features
10 Harry baby dolls in cardboard shaped
boxes with the title you can shave the
baby
perhaps the characters at the top of the
box do indicate that this product is
making a statement about the crazy toys
we know from Japan this toy went viral
but not a lot of people actually know
the real reason why exists in the first
place after all
art is open to interpretation but maybe
it's just best to leave this toy
uninterpreted and move on to the next on
our list lawn darts if you're from the
US and born before 1980 you'll remember
these lawn darts were a game that
involved throwing darts with weighted
metal tips into plastic rings it was fun
it made the kids active and it kept them
occupied for a while seems pretty
innocent right
well those 12-inch long metal tips were
actually pretty sharp and unfortunately
if they managed to cause several
injuries the last thing parents want is
to buy a toy that could potentially hurt
their kid and while it seems like it was
a lot of fun to throw the darts in the
circle and come up with different ways
to win the game
the piercing darts were too sharp for
children in 1980
the toy was officially banned if you're
looking for a toy similar to lawn darts
you're lucky because an alternative to
the sharp darts has been around since
1988
it's called Franklin Sports soft tipped
target toss and it's pretty much based
on the same concept but as you can guess
the tip of the dart is round and soft as
a bonus point these darts also light up
but you couldn't play with the original
lawn darts in the dark right don't go
anywhere because we have more odd kid
toys to show you our next toy is super
cool and we're actually really bummed it
got banned Atomic Energy Lab the Atomic
Energy Lab was one of the most
impressive toys that ever existed but
was it really meant for kids the toy was
perfect for those who love to experiment
and looking from the outside it seemed
pretty harmless the Atomic Energy Lab
was made in the 1950s and although you
might not be familiar with this toy we
met someone you know from an older
generation is the Atomic Energy Lab
could perform over a hundred and fifty
scientific experiments which sounds
awesome but unfortunately it had one
flaw the kit featured pieces of uranium
samples that came with the radioactive
warning label yes this kids toy featured
radioactive elements we thought there
would be no way this product would even
make it to the modern kids stores after
many parents had raised the radioactive
alarm the toy was pulled in the shelves
in 1952 just one year after it became
available while many argue that uranium
is not one of the most radioactive
elements out there the concern for
whether or not this was a completely
irresponsible kid's toy still remains
and let's not forget to mention that
this impressive radioactive kit cost a
whopping 50 bucks would you buy it or
would you spend it on something like our
next toy which is probably the weirdest
thing we've ever seen epidermis toy
makers really have no limit when it
comes to their imagination and we wonder
what these guys were thinking when they
decided to create epidermis even their
name makes it sound like it's anything
but a toy for children this toy belongs
to the company called carton designs and
they decided to beat all other toys on
our list by creating this unique thing
sure it's definitely unique but would
you ever play with epidermis the whole
purpose of this toy was to create
something completely obscene and watch
how the kids would interact the skin of
this thing almost resembles humans and
according to the developers this toy can
also walk using fuel cells for energy
and they also have a weird looking hair
at the front and are completely
customizable you can change their skin
tone hair color or even add a tattoo or
piercing which to be honest does sound
pretty cool
while we're sure there's just a much
deeper meaning behind this toy that
might actually make sense we can't help
but wonder who is this toy created for
is it really something a child would
play with or is it perhaps more suitable
for an adult we're not really sure it
could compete with fidget spinners
Barbie dolls Legos and other popular
interactive toy kits play with is this
what the future toys will look like sky
dancers have you ever wondered what
happened to sky dancers sky dancers were
similar to Barbie combined with a
helicopter toy they were on the market
from 1994 to 2000 so we've had many of
you probably played with this toy in
your childhood to make the dancers fly
all you have to do is pull the cord and
watch it fly off but there is an
unpredictable problem with this toy that
made it too dangerous to be played with
by kids these toys had propeller like
wings made of hard plastic and once they
were in the air they spun very fast and
could fly in random directions this
resulted in several injuries and could
cause temporary blindness as fascinating
as the sky dancers were the
uncontrollable spinning wings made the
toy hazardous Galoob the company behind
the toy had to recall almost 9 million
sky dancers sold gpsd also reported that
Galoob never issued a warning on the
toys dangers as a result they received
150 injury report which included eye
damage a mild concussion and other
facial injuries the toy makers didn't
really think this one through did they
if you're thinking about making toys for
a living
we hope you'll learn an important lesson
from this video and really make sure
your toys aren't actually children
friendly si si fingerprint examination
kit a CSI crime lab kit that lets you
take fingerprints and lets you become a
detective
sounds like a dream doesn't it you might
remember this best selling toy made by
CBS the kit was inspired by the popular
CSI show and it allowed you to take
fingerprints like a true professional
too bad this examination kit had to be
discontinued in 2008 because
a big problem the company was sued by an
asbestos victims organization which
managed to find potentially lethal
asbestos fibers in the fingerprint
powder considering this was meant for a
product for children CVS should make
sure it doesn't involve any harmful
substances inhaling asbestos can leave
the fibers to stay in your lungs for a
very long time and cause breathing and
inflammatory problems that can later
lead to threatening condition CVS agreed
to recall the toy public justice urged
parents to immediately get the product
out of their homes and keep it away from
children at all time
although CBS managed to produce several
awesome toys they failed to do the
simple child safety check with this one
speaking of child safety we're pretty
sure our next toy was not supposed to be
a toy in the first place it was pretty
common hundreds of years ago and it was
used to restrain people straightjacket
no matter what you think of children
this is one toy you should never give to
a kid check out this mock-up of a
straightjacket for kids that apparently
now comes in a cute bear design don't
worry though because these
straightjacket toys aren't real they
were made by a Brazilian company and
installed in an actual store to promote
new seasons of the super nanny show
although the original idea behind this
toy was meant to just a joke you can
actually find straight jackets for kids
on Amazon straight jackets were used to
keep unruly people as still as possible
you might also be familiar with straight
jackets if you're familiar with the
famous magician Harry Houdini who was
the first to successfully free himself
from the jacket us free jacket comes
with long sleeves and several buckles
which you pull to hold the person's
hands still to get out of it one must
have to perform some serious gymnastic
skills we know kids are awful at keeping
still but please don't ever put your
child in a straitjacket but there's a
toy out there that's so common and so
widespread that might even be more
bizarre than any other toy on our list
fidget spinners last but definitely not
least let's have a chat about fidget
spinners this toy craze is going out of
control and we bet you're playing with a
fidget spinner right now while their
primary purpose is to reduce anxiety and
help you focus in times when you just
can't stop fidgeting they can also be
very dangerous
of these spinning gadgets have now been
recalled from shops and supermarkets
because they contain small parts that
can be easily ingested the United
Kingdom's Trading Standards Institute
reports that they have found several
versions of these toys to be completely
unsuitable for children
many come with LED lights and sharp ends
but they fail to have warning labels
that ensure parents are aware of
potential hazards that come with the
toys if parts of it are accidentally
swallowed the Trading Standards
Institute also states that you should
always check the packaging and make sure
you only buy toys from a reputable
manufacturer an Australian mom reported
an incident of her child almost losing
an eye when throwing the digit spinner
in the air much like sky dancers these
toys can become sharp and as they spin
very fast they can easily cause
unpredicted damage the original fidget
spinner definitely wasn't meant for
children but let us know in the comments
if it helps you focus that's it for 10
toys that weren't supposed to be for
kids but if you want more make sure to
check out 10 strange raisins kid toys
were banned see you next time
[Music]